pueden ver alrededor mío esto se jóvenes
que están celebrando el triunfo de
Argentina son parte del asientos y
cientos diría miles de personas que
están acercando al obelisco que es el
epicentro de la ciudad de Buenos Aires
que está aquí atrás mío y se nota el
entusiasmo y el fervor por supuesto ante
el triunfo que es algo que se suele ver
en los triunfos de Argentina pero este
paso a finales clave Argentina mantiene
el invicto en semifinales en Copa del
Mundo y llega una final esperando por
saber si se enfrentará con Marruecos o
Francia luego de una actuación excelente
de la selección nacional ante el equipo
de Croacia natalio hay temores de que se
repita la historia 2014 o las esperanzas
esta vez están mucho más arriba
siempre hay esperanzas Este es un pueblo
que se ve con esperanza hoy por lo menos
después de ese después de ese triunfo
muy Sólido del equipo de Lionel canoci
escaloni de Lionel Messi antes Croacia
pensemos que antes del encuentro había
había cierto temor porque era un equipo
muy consolidado el de crosia también que
había dejado fuera de la Copa a Brasil y
sin embargo Argentina terminó
demostrando ser muy contundente Y eso da
por supuesto serias esperanzas a los
hinchas aquí en Argentina